people don't really understand how many
leaks occur at biosafety Labs even here
in the United States I mean that's
that's how people believe
what's the disease um lime Lyme disease
yeah a lot of people think Lyme disease
was the product of a of a BSL lab leak
uh that's on an island off the coast of
New York there's one in can I mean that
was a big thing for a while they were
building one in uh Fort Dietrich you
don't get to make all these movies where
the the scientist gets pricked through
their suit and they go oh God and they
run out and then have people think these
labs are completely safe yeah Lyme
disease was uh found near Lyme
Connecticut right and that's why they
call it Lyme disease they don't know
exactly where why I wouldn't be
surprised if it was I've heard the same
thing that it was done on an island like
a biomedical it's just like the idea of
federal government's like but that only
happens in movies movies are based
completely on fiction we would never do
anything like it